hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to show something a little bit
different from what i usually uh showing
you i would like to release the master
class that i've created actually one
year ago on the different elliot wave
patterns and how to use it so i'm gonna
release that in five parts so today is
gonna be about the motive waves uh once
again this was created one year ago and
was available in the membership area
where i'm gonna now post a new master
class and this one was for free starting
it's very fair that i share it with
everyone so the maximum of people can
benefit from it so please smash that
like button give me a comment and let's
give this video some views let's get
into it
[Music]
in the 1930s ralph as an idiot
discovered that market prices trend and
rivers into recognizable patterns which
can be explained by group behavioral on
mass psychology mechanisms
he observed that market's progression
unfolding waves just like anything in
this world that is growing
[Music]
he noticed that the forms repeat
themselves forever at different time
degrees just like fractals and therefore
have predictive value
he called this phenomenon the wave
principle
the theory which took him a lifetime is
still today the most used and the best
forecasting tool in existence when it
comes to training and i'm going to show
you guys how this is working and how to
use it let's get into it
[Music]
hey guys this is andrew from
trainsenses.com so welcome in my first
masterclass i'm very excited you guys
decided to join the idiot waves program
you are going to learn here an
incredible amount of information because
i put really hard work into this one as
all the team did and you know it's not
like my other youtube videos where of
course i put hard work but here i
decided to go really in depth of this
theory theory that is coming from a book
that i read that is not easy to read
guys it's called idiot wave principle
written by frost and pressure in the
1980s something like this rather than
idiot is actually from the 30s as you
saw in the short video clip introduction
and basically the theory is about market
co-structure it's basically saying that
the market is developing into waves so
there are different ways we are going to
see all of them you know there are
basically five patterns
and once you understand where you are in
the wave development which wave is
actually developing at the time you are
training you are going to be able to use
the other technical indicators much
better and to improve your training
results so i'm not sure what is your
goal guys if it's just to make you know
some
quick cash in a short uh period of time
if it's to be like a long-term investor
that is profitable in the long term uh
but anyways idiot wave principle is
going to help you to achieve those goals
so let's begin we are going to see first
the five different patterns so i'm gonna
guide you through this and then we're
gonna see some practice so i'm gonna
show you how i use it how to apply this
theory on the markets when you do live
training i'm gonna show you some
examples some past examples and some
short video clips where i use the theory
before some moves happen and actually it
helped me to predict what would happen
chapter one basics of idiot wave theory
so i i really did my best to make things
uh accessible for everyone because as i
said the book that i've read
is uh really not easy to read it took me
like maybe i read it in total three
times because i was reading something i
was not getting you know the full
information of it so i was reading it
again i was writing notes i was you know
trying to try to read it guys you're
gonna see but after maybe this course
it's gonna be easier and i encourage for
those who want to understand even more
than what i'm going to give you here
to read this book so you have motive
waves and you have corrective waves all
right so motive waves are basically
waves that are going into the direction
of the market so when the market is
bullish motive waves are waves that are
going up so those waves are can be an
impulse or a diagonal so they always
have in it five waves as well then you
have the corrective waves so you have
the zigzag the flat and the triangle so
those five figures so they can have
three or five waves zigzag and flat they
have three waves and triangle has five
waves so here are the five patterns that
you're gonna see everywhere in the
market it's and actually the other way
around is true as well every pattern
that you see in the market is one of
those five so now i'm going to give you
some rules that are going to help you to
actually identify what pattern you are
looking at so let's begin with the
impulse so the impulse is the most
iconic pattern of idiot waves uh theory
it's something you see everywhere so i'm
gonna
show you how it works it has five waves
all right first rule three motif waves
and two corrective waves so one two
three
four and five all right so one
three and five those uh that are in
green are the motif waves all right
because this is a wave up
and the inside this pattern what is
going up is motive so one three five i'm
a motive and two and four you know the
red ones they are corrective waves so
this is the first rule of an impulse it
has five waves then wave two never goes
below wave one alright so basically this
the bottom of the wave of the second
wave cannot go below here all right it
cannot
go below the starting of wave one
otherwise this won't be impulsive you
know an impulse is something that is
strong and that is you know uh really
pushing the market direction of the wave
so for example up in this situation wave
three is never the shortest so this is
to me the most important rule of an
impulse it's basically that the third
wave cannot be the shortest but it's
usually the strongest it's usually as
well an impulse itself so it has usually
five waves inside it and it's very
helpful once you see a very strong and
powerful move on the market usually you
can start from there and assume this
this is a third so it's very helpful to
actually then identify one two and
potentially four and five that are
coming then wave three always goes
beyond wave one so this is kind of a
basic rule but same stuff you know this
needs to go up this needs to be
impulsive so the third wave must of
course go above the highest level of
wave one and very important one as well
wave four never enters wave one guys so
wave four is starting here finishing
here so this bottom cannot go
below here
all right guys it cannot go here
because otherwise this would be weak you
see the fact that this level here is
higher than this one
means that actually the buying power is
very strong in this pattern and this is
actually
what is making it an impulse i would
like to discuss with you guys what is
the meaning behind each
wave of the impulse
so wave one actually so before an
impulse usually you have a strong move
down and then
you have the rebound so we call the bias
of the first wave of an impulse the
precursors because those guys they are
the first to spot that the market is
shifting so for different reasons it can
be fundamental or it can be technical
but those guys are the first to buy and
they actually uh invert the powers of uh
the bertrand that was before this
impulse then you have the contrarians so
contrarians
are people who like to basically take
the opposite direction of uh every
strong move they see you probably know
people like this i mean you know once
something is going up too much
or you know for them it's too much but
nobody knows if it's too much or not
they usually like to sell what's the
reason behind just because they are
waiting for this correction you know so
they're contrarians and they usually for
example they start they're gonna start
selling here they're gonna sell more
here more here they're gonna average
their position and then they're gonna
play this whole move down
so
it's like a type of training
then you have the institutional clients
that are entering in the game what i
call the smart money guys because those
people
so they are professionals of market they
can be hedge funds asset managers banks
people who analyze the fundamentals
people who saw that the market has
shifted and that are waiting for these
contrarians to give them a nice level to
buy so those guys they're gonna start
buying here they're even gonna start
buying here they're gonna buy here here
here everywhere here and they're gonna
push this market higher this is the
reason why the third wave is so strong
so the volume are very strong as well
guys in this third wave because uh those
investors they arrive with big money and
they do the same trade uh all together
so they're gonna push the market very
very high then you have natural type of
investors do the people who bought like
for example here
here here you know those guys that
basically buy everywhere and the asset
managers and hedge funds that are buying
here
they need to take profit all right at
the time so they're going to start
selling here here here here and they are
they're gonna create this fourth wave
all right so for now we have kind of
only professionals of the market you
know
and this can be true in uh you know
shorter time frame or even in a bigger
time frame so for example this can be
for example few weeks a few days of your
month and usually after that you have
what i call the ships it's people who
heard that people around them are making
a lot of money
and they become greedy they want to do
the same thing they are thinking why not
me
the market is just going out you know
and it's been usually let's say it's
like few months and they are like you
know very confident in the fact that
this market is very strong and then it
cannot go down all right this is what we
have before each crisis guys this is
what we have in 2000 the internet bubble
this is what we had in 2007
this is what we had in
1928
right before the the biggest crisis ever
the 1929 crisis and this is typical
behaviors of retail investors usually
those guys you know who don't know
anything about the market and who just
want to make some easy money and
actually what is funny is that the
people who are actually gonna sell here
and take some short positions against
those people are the same guys that
about that are buying here so
you know they buy here they sell here so
usually they sell to the ships and then
the ships buy more and they're gonna
keep sending to them and eventually the
market is gonna revert we're gonna have
some kind of a correction that can last
same few weeks month or even years it
depends on the time frame you're looking
but it's always the same phenomenon so
ask yourself where we are right now guys
to me so this is another discussion but
very quickly i can give you my view we
are i think at the beginning of this
fifth wave and the the fifth wave can
last long a long time all right so i
think we're at the beginning of it so
maybe we're gonna have a big rally for
the coming uh year or two years
uh and then we're gonna have a market
reversion i'm done with the impulse like
i said it's i'm gonna come back to this
because actually once we're gonna see
all the other uh patterns you're gonna
see that they are all related to this
one so this is the most iconic one this
is the one that you always need to keep
in mind try to remember these rules and
to practice it and to try to recognize
an impulse when you see it
let's go to the next pattern
which is the diagonal all right so
diagonal is a motif wave as well it's
the second type of magic waves so
diagonal has few rules as well so some
of them are same as the impulse so for
example it has five waves all right
three motif waves two corrective waves
so same thing one
three and five are motive waves and two
and four are corrective waves all right
so this is the same thing way wave two
never moves below wave one same stuff
all right because it needs to go up
wave three is never the shortest so same
here you know wave three cannot be the
shortest from here to here you're always
going to have more than from here to
here or from here to here and this is a
rule that i'm going to show you guys how
you can use for example uh to predict
where wave five can go if wave three is
shorter than wave one like here then you
know that wave five cannot go above for
example this level otherwise wave three
would be the shortest so if you are
right about a motive wave you can easily
predict uh in some situations a maximum
level that wave five cannot go above
then wave three goes below wave one same
star for right
here it needs to be lower than here
and this is guys so the most important
rule of diagonal is that wave four
always enters with one all right so this
is wave one as you can see all right and
wave four is below is here little wave
one what is this telling you guys it's
basically just telling you that the
market has weakness all right it's not
like for the impulse for the impulse let
me remind you guys how it was uh you
know the market was buying here much
higher so wave four could not go below
wave one for the diagonal actually this
is showing weakness this is showing that
the market is out of steam so usually we
see diagonals they can be leading on or
ending i mostly see ending diagonals so
they are the fifth wave of uh usually
this you know the fifth wave would be an
ending diagonal and it's usually gonna
be in this kind of wedge pattern so
which pattern is uh when you have two
the support level and the resistance uh
level that are just converging to a same
point and here usually you have a very
low volatility right the market is just
consolidating and then usually you have
a breakout on the downside so very you
know interesting information and very
useful is that when you see wave four
entering wave one you know that this is
probably an ending diagonal so if you're
able to identify one two three four
before then you know it's the last uh
pattern of the of an impulse for example
and that you're probably gonna have uh
the market reverting very soon and wave
four never goes below wave two all right
so you know it
it's still a multi wave so wave four
cannot go here all right if it was like
this then it's a corrective pattern it's
not a motive wave anymore so that's it
for the diagonal i'm gonna once again
show you some practical uh use of all
this information once you spot it